[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous bienvenue
dans votre nouveau rendez vous
hebdomadaire que j'ai le plaisir de
présenter avec vous jean-marc partie oui
bon c'est encore il n'est bien venu en
politique pays notre invité aujourd'hui
le président du conseil exécutif de la
ctm serge letchimy
[Musique]
bonsoir monsieur jimmy bon soir
bonsoir monsieur le président du conseil
exécutif de la ctm merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors dans cette
émission il sera question du rôle et de
la place de la ctm dans cette crise
sanitaire et évidemment nous aborderons
bain les conséquences économiques de
cette quatrième vague mais avant
d'aborder tous ces thèmes découvrons
avec vous jean marc parti qui se cache
derrière le titre de bce serge de chibi
personnages politiques importants 1 s'il
en est mais vous êtes aussi un
personnage de roman en l'occurrence
celui de patrick chamoiseau et dont le
roman texaco en porte le nom du quartier
dans lequel vous un roman dans laquelle
vous confier un urbaniste venir et
réaménager ce quartier populaire situé
non loin d'ici ce qui a valu d'ailleurs
à son mentor patrick chamoiseau le prix
goncourt en 1992 mais en réalité la
fiction et le réel se joignent puisque
vous êtes vraiment un urbaniste de
profession après avoir décroché votre
doctorat à la sorbonne en 1984 à 68 ans
aujourd'hui vous abondez et nouvelle
étape une nouvelle phase de votre vie
politique déjà riche commencé il ya près
de trente ans maintenant avec votre
élection pour conseil général sont
l'ehpad camille darsières une dizaine
d'années après votre adhésion parti
progressiste martiniquais depuis vous
n'avez cessé de d'aqmi des
responsabilités politiques et victoire
électorale maire de fort de france en
2001 président de la cacem la même année
président du ppm député en 2007 réélu
deux fois et président du conseil
régional en 2010 avant d'être du conseil
exécutif
aujourd'hui en 2021 vous avez été un
parlementaire actifs d'après les
archives de l'assemblée nationale
puisque vous êtes l'auteur ou le
coauteur de trois lois concernant la vie
dans les outre-mers une première loi sur
l'habitat indigne une autre si la
coopération régionale et enfin la loi
anti à l'indivision successorale
je rappelle que partisan fervent de
l'autonomie vous avait théorisé votre
pensée politique dans un livre programme
discours sur l'autonomie en 2002 et je
terminerai en rappelant que vous avez
été footballeur au sein de l'équipe du
goût de et de la sélection de la
martinique avant durant les années 1990
être entraîneur du club olympique de
treand alors serge letchimy avant d'être
un homme politique on écoute vous étiez
donc un footballeur comme nous l'a dit
jean marc alors commence une question à
vous poser sur le terrain politique
vous êtes plutôt attaquant ou défenseurs
les deux à la fois à la fois il faut
pour mieux défendre il faut attaquer
aussi donc les deux à la fois mais bon
c'est pas croyable comparables quand
même ce sont des postes fixes canton un
football en politique il faut absolument
parfaitement connaître ses dossiers et
se montrer suffisamment sobre précis
clairs nets et honnête pour conduire les
affaires du pays
la ville du sujet nous sommes en pleine
période de rentrée scolaire alors que
nous sommes confinés entourant en grande
partie même s'il ya un certain nombre de
mesures d'allégement entre en vigueur
aujourd'hui lundi 26 au mercredi 22 mais
nous n'entendons pas beaucoup la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
au sujet de cette rentrée la 7e qui je
le rappelle est responsable l'équipement
et de l'entretien des collèges et des
lycées si vous n'entendez pas la
collectivité territoriale matinik sé
passe quelque chose se passe tellement
bien on n'a pas besoin d'en parler
beaucoup on est plutôt en actions plutôt
que le faire des déclarations et vous
savez de la rentrée toujours compliqué
on a de rentrée
la rentrée des pluies pendant cette
période là il faut toujours se préparer
à une innovation ainsi goal des rentrées
scolaires on a malgré notre connexion
vers le fin du mois de juin et début
juillet on a quand même bien préparer la
rentrée on a multiplié les réunions
parce que je connais bien ce sujet et
n'a pu avec les directeurs que je
remercie des proviseurs que je vous
remercie mais aussi les syndicats qui
ont activement participé parce qu'il y
avait des protocoles a bâtie au pied
mais aussi avec des salariés on a eu
très très peu de problèmes parce que
nous sommes en responsables des collèges
et les lycées on a aussi anticipé parce
que vous avez il ya toujours des travaux
et j'ai voulu absolument qu'il n'y ait
pas de faille s'est jamais bien
totalement bien fait mais qui est pas de
faille qu'on soit prêt à répondre à
toutes les questions
monsieur le président du conseil
exécutif on sait que l'écho de cette
crise sanitaire sur les réseaux sociaux
tend à banaliser voire carrément à
discréditer la parole des experts la
parole des scientifiques mais également
avec la parole des élus nous sommes dans
une quatrième vague d mais les médecins
parlent de tsunami c'est une vague
extrêmement meurtrière
moi j'ai une question pour vous ce soir
vous vous positionnez pour la
vaccination ou contre la vaccination
c'est surprenant la question parce
qu'elle faisait tout le monde y est ma
position concernant la vaccination je
suis contre l'obligation vaccinale
globale et générale je considère que
bien c'est un sujet que suffisamment
sensible pour ne pas rentrer dans une
obligation vaccinale général par contre
je suis pour la vaccination parce que je
considère que c'est le seul moyen que
nous avons aujourd'hui s'il ya d'autres
moyens on verra pour nous permettre
d'éviter des formes graves de la maladie
avait des comorbidités très souvent qui
conduit à la mort je rappelle quand même
on l'a dépassée dès 500 morts c'est
énorme et surtout pendant de celui mis
trois semaines on a touché à peu près
entre 200 et 300 morts sa députation en
calculer ça par rapport à la population
de l'hexagone ce serait 60 7000
personnes qui mouraient enfants si on
appliquait le taux de mortalité pendant
cette période là donc c'est une
catastrophe c'est une hécatombe et j'ai
eu l'occasion à l'hôpital de la meynard
de voir des soignants en très grande
difficulté souffrir vraiment souffrir
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que nous aurons
mené plusieurs opérations de soutien aux
soignants et on a vécu autre chose qui
m'a été très douloureux pour moi c'est
de voir des gens dans des sacs parce
qu'il ya plus de place dans des casiers
de réfrigération de voir des êtres
humains dans des sacs et mon royaume et
puis voir des professionnels de santé
qui sont condamnés à touiller le moudre
et du très violent mais je le dis à
trier entre des jeunes et des personnes
âgées laura ouais ça eh bien on peut
dire on peut avoir des interprétations
on ne peut dire qu'il faut chercher des
solutions de soutien extérieur le
soutien intérieur et de tout faire pour
éviter une saturation est extrêmement
grave ça l'était déjà qu'est-ce que
d'après vous en tant que responsable
politique de longue date comme nous le
disions tout à l'heure qu'est ce qui
explique que la population martiniquaise
guadeloupéenne de la montre de la même
mesure est aussi refera t on voit
hostiles à se faire vacciner moi je veux
pas du tout je n'ai jamais fait
stigmatiser des anti vaccins jamais
insulté ni jeter l'opprobre etc et il ya
des choses qu'il faut comprendre la
première chose c'est que les hésitations
les hésitations du gouvernement pas de
masque c'est pas utile c'est utile à
l'accession est utile
la construction même du vaccin peut
conduire à ce que des gens aient des
doutes rm message et c'est qui ça c'est
pas un vaccin classique je peux
comprendre qu'il ait des préoccupations
pia ça c'est pour les incertitudes parce
qu'elle ne grosse part de personnes qui
sont dans l'incertitude et puis vous
avez aussi des personnes qui sont
éthiquement contre la vaccination il
faut respecter ces gens la seule chose
c'est qu'il faut assumer ses
responsabilités clairement et de manière
très transparente dire que nous n'avons
pas aujourd'hui d'autre solution et à ce
titre là je peux considérer que la
science peut faire des évolutions je
peux considérer y compris que certains
médicaments qu'on indique peuvent
apporter des solutions mais pour
l'instant c'est pas utilisables au sens
pur du terme éviter d'avoir la maladie
c'est avoir la maladie est traitée la
maladie samba guèye mais évitez de la
voie la seule solution qu'on a c'est
cela c'est dans ce cadre là que nous
travaillons activement à persuader on
n'oblige personne mais à persuader et je
pense qu'il faut absolument continuer
dans cet axe quel est le maître mot de
la politique de la ctm dans la crise
sanitaire parce qu'on entend peu je vais
peut être un peu ma question de talent
on entende relativement peu la 7e
s'exprimer sur ce qu'il convient de
faire attend il veut tenir effectivement
quelques déclarations quelques décisions
qui ont été prises je
suis parti je pense que je vous fais une
compilation à la fois des communiqués de
la collectivité territoriale comme ça
vous verrez une attractivité du oui
alors que nous recevons vous recevez une
serbe s'avérer parole brute qui à part
le but aller puis à simplement le fait
qu'on puisse communiquer de manière très
sobre ce que nous faisons sur la ctn
fait et vous verrez que ça n'était pas
très bien perçue par l'opinion publique
forcément mais une part de l'opinion
publique peut ne pas être d'accord sur
nos positions mais c'est pas parce
qu'une part n'est pas d'accord je
comprends et je respecte que la
communication que nous faisons et des
actions que le faisons et ne ne sont pas
bien mises en évidence je pense que la
collectivité territoriale droit joue un
rôle majeur dans cette affaire c'est à
dire ne pas simplement se contenter de
ne pas déclarer ce que vaut ne pas être
là de dire si la sphère de l'état on se
nourrit pas parce qu'il ya les désordres
non je pense qu'il faut être très
présent donc nous avons mené de très
nombreuses actions mais que vous n'avez
pas vu l'espoir que vous faites passer
la martinique premier à sénou et les
anti sexistes campo vaccination les
postes offerts des images que vous voyez
des élus c'est aussi nous les repas qui
ont été offertes pour soutenir les
soignants c'est nous dans les hôpitaux
les musiciens que vous voyez jouer pour
atténuer intitulé l'arrêt eu de
l'ambiance qu'il y a c'est nous le fait
d'avoir et accompagner très fortement
l'hôpital en débloquant 9 millions
d'euros pour leur permettre de pouvoir
mieux s'équiper c'est nous et puis
dernière chose on a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle et djogbénou la tiens bon
on est là simplement parce que on avait
besoin de répondre à une des demandes
des syndicats et notamment du chu où des
syndicats de santé qui disait attention
la médecine de ville la méditer
l'historial le contact avec la famille
le fait de les accompagner parce qu'il
ya des difficultés à mon i4 mona enfants
mini cat man ni trois kim ho est acquis
rite est vivant c'est celui qui à 93 ans
donc il faut s'en occuper
donc avec les ccas avec les maires on a
déjà signé six conventions d'assurer une
prise en charge plus complète en
oxygénation de faire des oxymètres de
fournit des oxymètres pour mesurer le
taux d'oxygène dans le sang pour
travailler avec les médecins libéraux
pour assurer une continuité sur le
terrain c'est non le fait d'ouvrir
à sainte luce maxime nous droit c'est
nous et à basse pointe aussi ouvrir et
bien sûr nous aurons le vaccine nos bus
qui va circuler en martinique l'action
que nous menons est extrêmement
important mais nous respectons le cadre
défini par la rs et d'état qui ont la
responsabilité en matière de santé mais
nous sommes extrêmement proches et
chaque fois que des syndicalistes
veulent nous rencontrer nous sommes là
vous y allé ailleurs entendre les
contradictions quelquefois on connaît
par serge letchimy trente ans que vous
êtes sur le terrain politique vous êtes
un homme politique d'ailleurs qu'on ne
présente plus président du conseil
régional aujourd'hui président du
conseil exécutif face à cette pandémie
est-ce que vous avez pour la première
fois de votre carrière politique
rencontrer des difficultés oui difficile
c'est ce temps c'est un des moments les
plus durs et j'ai rencontré jean les
rencontrer mais face à ce tsunami comme
on dit des fois on est dans
l'incertitude c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'il faut pas
ridiculiser brimer violenté insulté des
anti vaccins je pense qu'il faut
continuer est ce que nous faisons pas
seulement parce que lorsque vous êtes
face à une telle réalité et si j'ai une
crainte a exprimé sa cinquième bague il
faut je veux pas
avoir de mauvais présages mais je
considère qu'aujourd'hui le risque ce
n'est pas tant d'avoir une cinquième
bague c'est pour cela que aujourd'hui le
niveau de vaccination fragilise une
résistance globale par rapport
l'éventualité de nouveaux variants qui
peut arriver et qui va être beaucoup
plus violent que le delta et à ce titre
là nous sommes très prudents c'est pour
ça avec les saad nous faisons un travail
avec les personnes âgées qui sont dans
nos centres d'hébergements avec nos
propres salariés on a quand même 4300 à
4700 salariés ont fait un travail en a
perdu déjà six personnes à la
collectivité territoriale donc c'est un
vrai boulot de résistance qu'il faut
structurer et dans le respect de chacun
alors serge et timmy nous sommes
maintenant vous mettre face à des
acteurs économiques ils ont été
bousculés par cette crise sanitaire il
s'agit de deux directeurs de salles de
sport et l'un d'entre eux a été le
représentant du collectif des non
essentiels écoutez la question qu'ils
ont à vous poser
bonjour de cette présidence bush yvon
directeur d'une salle de sport et
christophe blain nomme présidents des
clubs de sport en martinique nous avons
2 questions et une suggestion
jeunesse dans bonjour les restaurants
les salles de sport doivent appliquer un
pass à lutter pour notre secteur la
secteur sportif cela s'avère difficile
voire impossible car les clients sont
soumis à la prise d'un abonnement annuel
d'ailleurs nous sommes en pleine rentrée
nous suggérons donc l'annulation ou
l'adaptation du pass sanitaires et nous
vous demandons quel accompagnement était
prévu à court moyen et long terme compte
tenu de la perte de notre saison et
pourront nous vous rencontrer rapidement
afin de vous exposer nos difficultés et
a
parlé des solutions éventuellement on ne
pourrait y apporter je vous remercie
voilà ce que j'assimile questions en
direct quand aurez-vous rencontré les
représentants de la fédération des yeux
tous les jours des salles de sport jo je
reçois beaucoup et il ya pas de problème
les rencontres il me semble qu'on sait
déjà rencontré déjà donc il ya pas
difficulté mon cabinet pour leurs
contacts pour cool qu'elle rencontre
concernant l'accompagnement et je
réponds pas seulement à cette activité
là qui englobe d'autres activités qu'on
appelle des non essentiels qui ont été
fermés et nous avons obtenu arish alice
et moi par un courrier qu'on a transmis
vers juin je pense que vous l'avez eue à
wisches à disposition de la légende le
bruit et le président a peur de l'autre
nous avons exigé que l'état puisse
remettre les aides de solidarité et la
prise en charge du chômage partiel par
l'état ça a été actée la réponse a été
très positif rapidement cependant
l'arrêt le décret d'application qui
était mise en oeuvre n'était pas adaptée
à la réalité donc nous avons décidé
d'exiger une bonification des décrets et
donc les aides d'état qu'existait pour
la deuxième première deuxième et
troisième vague vont commencer à
s'organiser à se structurer qui se
divise en plusieurs choses la voyant
chose c'est le temps partiel la deuxième
chose c'est la solidarité de l'état avec
trois niveaux dead et entreprises qui
sont fermés les ombres bisky qui
subissent après en deux catégories nous
avons décidé aussi de reconduire l'aide
de la collectivité territoriale sa
réponse directement à ses deux
interlocuteurs et nous allons voter bien
sûr à l'assemblée qui est présidée par
notre président monsieur ça libère
lucien nous allons fautes et les aide on
prévoit environ entre autour de 30
millions globalement 30 millions d'
aides à accorder aux activités bien sûr
c'est jamais suffisant mais c'est une
somme énorme qui pourrait nous permettre
de donner un petit coup de pouce au coup
de pouce emballant ne pas les laisser
sans rien du tout parce qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup d'entreprises et nous
avons cadré notre aide non pas seulement
dans la foulée des aides de l'état pour
ne pas faire ce que l'état fait déjà et
nous avons aussi travaillé sur des
critères pour permettre aux entreprises
locales de mieux être soutenu que le
reste est sous le standard de l'état
donc il ya deux ailes de solidarité
complémentaires on a prévu aussi un prêt
à taux zéro pour quelle raison parce
qu'on considère qu'il ya des entreprises
qui peuvent pas avoir un peu plus mais
avec un engagement plus important et on
a ciblé aussi les activités
très sensible je pense aux artistes des
musiciens les artistes d'une manière
générale et un cadre spécial où des
artistes et surtout et aussi des
agriculteurs on avait oublié on hors
billet agriculteurs pêche sont les
oubliés donc nous avons prévu c est là
et on doit voter bientôt et puis
concernant le pass annie terre sain
sujet très complexe qui est très
complexe il faut accepter dans des bains
moi je l' ai dit à plusieurs reprises
devant les pompiers mais devons aussi
peu tout le monde
l'application du plan sanitaire en
institution c'est compliqué a bien sûr
qu'il ya des métiers qui sont très
exposées aux des métiers qui peuvent
avoir des relations notamment à dire le
sentier qui sont exposés mais pour la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
j'avais décidé de ne pas appliquer à la
lettre que le pass and i ter recevoir
parce que je considérais qu'on pouvait
aussi avoir des tests à l'entrée pour
les personnes qui pour savoir si la
personne est touché ou pas la somme en
prenant en charge le test la question
est différente dans un restaurant d'un
an
dans ce cinéma et j'ai eu l'occasion de
le voir de voir ça fonctionne et à paris
que j'étais en mission
et pouvoir le gouvernement les gas
associée aux violeurs et j'ai constaté
que l'implication du passani terre et
dans les restaurants avec les nouvelles
dynamiques de fonctionnement des
restaurants a ici ce qui est peut-être
pas très bien c'est qu'elle est à la
fois grâce à une telle démesure les
distanciation très élevé je trouve que
c'est pas compatible vous me rappelez
avec même partir de la population
vaccinée ça va limiter tout de même
willard et des clients vous allez leur
enlève cinéma ou dans les combien ça je
peux vous dire que les salles de
restauration sont bondés ce qui veut
dire qu'il ya un lien entre
malheureusement entre heureusement entre
le passage du ter et puis l'occupation
l'activité des restaurants je pense que
et le pinceau ni d'air a de bons côtés à
de mauvais côté et il faut s'adapter à
l'application est il possible
d'envisager une adaptation purement
local martiniquaise même bon je pense
que la première chose c'est que vous
avez bien que le gouvernement a retardé
l'application du pas salutaire dans les
milieux de santé et c'est donc une
première adaptation déjà qu'ils effect
la deuxième chose c'est que dans les
institutions collectivités j'ai préféré
offrir la possibilité se fait attesté
plutôt que d'appliquer comme ça le passé
l'inter autrement eh bien j'ai 90 à 100
salariés si nécessaire un pouce en kippa
l'ama peut pas fonctionner donc on était
souple et la deuxième chose je pense que
concernant les activités commerciales il
faut vraiment les soutenir c'est la
question qui est posée pour pouvoir
faire appliquer les passages le pass
annie taire parce que ça permet de
renforcer progressivement
l'usagé l'utilisation du lieu en toute
sécurité sans pour cela qu'on est des
gens qui commencent à douter je vous
donne un exemple on a des fois qu'elle
peut faire quelqu'un qui malade d'un
service j'ai connu ça à la collectivité
territoriale et qui est atteint par la
plus vide qui même décédé eh bien vous
avez une situation très
fragilisante qui s'installe dans le
service anxiogène ah oui c'est ça donc
il faut quand même tenir compte de ça le
pass and i ter appliquée dans certains
activité ça peut aussi y contribuer à la
bonne utilisation des lieux alors
précisément si simple de la ducasse
sanitaires nous vous proposons une
question de civils maréchal c'est la
présidente du groupement des employeurs
des structures d'aidé à la personne que
vous avez déjà eu l'occasion de
rencontrer et qui elle est inquiète sur
la manière d'appliquer ses modalités de
la mesure où les aides à domicile risque
de se retrouver sans emploi reste si
elles ne peuvent pas la présenter ce pas
sanitaires nous l'écoutons
bonsoir
président quelle place allez vous
accordez au service d'aidé et
d'accompagnement à domicile durant votre
mandature et quel levier pensez vous
actionnez dans quel délai compte tenu de
la situation sanitaire que nous
traversons
csid maréchal pose une question beaucoup
plus globale que le pathfinder et l'a
d'ailleurs raison parce que c'est une
ville où des traîtres et mieux ce sujet
elle est même elle est actrice vous
savez les fades ses environs et services
d'aidé à domicile c'est 49 entreprises
c'est énorme c'est pratiquement 1600
salariés qui s'occupent globalement de
la moitié du nombre de personnes aidées
en apa et pch c'est à dire les de
l'autonomie des personnes âgées ses
environs près de 6000 personnes qui ont
se chargent l'esad donc c'est
extrêmement important donc là nous
voulons pour répondre à sylvie très
clairement nous voulons donner une place
contre très importante à la question de
la prise en charge des personnes âgées
on sera très vigilant sur
l'organisation et des conséquences
actuelles sulaco vide nous sommes aussi
déterminé aussi à remonter ce qu'on
appelle le niveau horaire et en termes
de prise en charge qui tout au taux de
19 euros et a passé autour de 21 euros
mais on va faire des expertises avant
nous devons aussi les accompagner en
matière de formation au moins des sables
c'est fondamental et fait très prudents
ou la la la la fin du chèque cesu pour
qu'on n'ait pas et au niveau des sables
mais au niveau des individus aussi qui
les familles qui prennent d'autres
membres de la famille pour les
accompagner éviter que les personnes
âgées deviennent des salariés durant les
vraiment dessus et il faut absolument
améliorer
fluidité du traitement des dossiers
c'était c'est trop lent c'est pas bon
concernant le pass and i t elle je veux
simplement attirer l'attention attention
on a affaire à des personnes âgées très
âgés et qui font qu'on soit conscient
que ses personnages aux contrées en
domicile là à la fois il faut vous
protéger et le salarié il faut aussi que
la personnages soient protégés donc nous
allons travailler autour de ça pour les
aider et s'il le faut mais il faut
absolument comme je le fais à la
collectivité de la ctm avant la même
attitude pour accompagner accompagner
les personnes professionnels des salles
à se faire vacciner parce que madame
maréchal redoute et c'est une avalanche
de démission de personne qui préfère lui
dire écoute et on ne va pas se faire
vacciner contre la vaccination préfère
démissionner je me fais je pouvais être
optimiste je vous fais et voir avec les
ca des on doit faut absolument qu'on les
rencontre est rapidement pu leur donner
les moyens pour susciter pour éviter
l'émission bon mais je je passais ces
deux quand même de dire nous avons la
responsabilité de la protection d'une
personne de 93 ans 98 parce que si un gc
caitlin voyage fragilisée et on a été
très très dur dans nos centres
d'hébergement de personnes âgées ou les
visites aux étés et régulier à peu de
choses on a mis un protocole sanitaire
très sévère et dieu merci on n'a pas eu
trop de dégâts ces derniers temps et
dans ces centres d'hébergement de
personnes âgées très bien nous allons
devoir continuer à avancer un peu dans
cette émission et c'est l'heure du
dialogue avec un invité ce soir c'est le
docteur 8 10 valentino réanimateurs
n'homologue également directeur de
l'espace de réflexion éthique régional
de martinique ou chu docteur valentino
bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
alors une quatrième vague qu'ovide qui a
déferlé en martinique durant les grandes
vacances et ce mois de septembre
également de nombreux médecins et même
le président du conseil exécutif parle
de tsunami il s'agit d'une catastrophe
sanitaire sans précédent pouvez vous
nous expliquer pourquoi docteur
valentino
écouter bonsoir à tous monsieur le
président du conseil exécutif bonsoir
merci perd de la vitesse
écoutez le le mot tsunami oui parce que
nous avons été effectivement
submergés par l'afflux de malades
nous avons dû faire face à des patients
extrêmement graves nécessitant une prise
en charge en réanimation et malgré tous
les efforts qui ont été faits malgré la
multiplier la multiplication par 5 des
lits de réanimation nous avons pas pu
soigner tous les patients avec les soins
de approprié à leur état ça a été une
réalité nous l'avons plusieurs fois
informer la population
du débordement du sud et des services de
la meynard nous avons été littéralement
submergé alors
nous avons au cours des 10 mois de
juillet du mois d'août
reçus rien qu en réanimation environ 350
malades
inutile de préciser que jusqu'ici à la
date du 17 septembre nous avions au
maximum trois patients complètement
vaccinés c'est à dire ayant reçu les
deux doses
7 cette épidémie a fait des ravages en
martinique sur cette quatrième vague un
martiniquais sur 700 de plus de 12 ans
est décédée c'est ça qui s'est passé en
six semaines c'était une épreuve pour le
système hospitalier c'était aussi une
épreuve pour les familles pour les
proches les amis qu'ils ont perdu des
familles décimées monsieur le président
du conseil exécutif la tenue tout à
l'heure
c'était une épreuve aussi pour les
soignants les soignants qui sont qui ont
été présents qui se sont battus des
infirmières des aides soignants de
secrétariat les tous ceux qui font
tourner un hôpital dans ces conditions
abominables
tous étaient sur le front est en malgré
cela nous avons été débordés malgré tous
les efforts qui ont été fort ou alors
maintenant
il faut plutôt que de critiquer des
décisions
dans un contexte impossible des
décisions difficiles dans un contexte
impossible ce qui s'est passé en
martinique ça s'est produit dans l'est
de la france ça s'est produit dans le
nord de l'italie ça s'est produit à
paris à new york maintenant il va
falloir réfléchir à l'avenir tout faire
pour éviter
la circulation de ce virus et je crois
que nos concitoyens savent ce qu'il faut
faire aujourd'hui
ils ont je crois compris la nécessité
d'éviter la transmission de ce virus en
respectant les gestes barrière en
s'isolant quand on est malade en se
faisant tester le plus tôt possible et
faire tester son entourage et notamment
les plus fragiles de façon à éviter la
transmission de ce virus et de ce
variant qui est devenu bien plus
contagieux il faut aussi je crois que
les nos concitoyens ont compris la
nécessité de la vaccination
l'expérience à travers le monde
maintenant est suffisamment grande et
précise pour rassurer nos concitoyens
quant à l'efficacité et la sécurité de
la vaccination parce qu'elle vient en
complément indispensable aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à contrôler la circulation
de ce virus diminuer les
hospitalisations de formes sévères et
prévenir les décès d'autant plus que
nous avons cette rentrée scolaire vous
en avez parlé tout à l'heure à réussir
et les données scientifiques récentes
montrent que nos collégiens nos lycéens
sont aussi porteurs de ce virus et est
un et ce sont une population
vecteur du virus auprès des parents des
grands pas docteur valentino
réanimateurs pneumologue merci beaucoup
de votre témoignage sur cette crise
sanitaire
exception mais
monsieur le président du conseil
exécutif alors on l'a entendu une crise
vous l'aviez vous même dit un tsunami
que retenir justement de ce témoignage
vraiment très forts du docteur menti
depuis des mois je suis
très touché par la sobriété des propos
et des mots choisis par le club
valentino un homme sans qui maîtrise
parfaitement son sujet et
d'une très grande cohérence et
expliquent des choses qui doivent à mon
avis être le fond du raisonnement la
base du raisonnement qu'on devrait avoir
on est face à quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave nous sommes face à
quelque chose qui tue nous sommes des
face à quelque chose qui ne concerne pas
que la martinique il a plus d exemple le
monde entier et à ce titre là nous
devons absolument tenir compte du fait
que la martinique a perdu beaucoup de
monde il faut absolument éviter que ça
continue
sont tout à fait louables
c'est un décompte malheureusement
macabre le 7 septembre
triste triste record malheureusement
record macabre la martinique
comptabilisé 500 morts le 7 septembre
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 20 septembre
il y à 594 mort c'est-à-dire
94 décès en l'espace de treize jours
l'hécatombe continue visiblement même si
les contaminations tendance à baisser
les derniers chiffres sont quand même
affolant type possible d'envisager une
sorte de collaboration entre vous entre
élus de la martinique est justement ces
professionnels de la santé pour freiner
cette hémorragie mais c'est ce qui est
en cours le chef que vos données est
extrêmement grave
on est passé d'un mort il ya des quatre
cinq mois à près de quinze morts par
jour par jour et on savait que la chute
de nombre de contaminés ne faisait
nevers en rien la présence massive de
personnes qui rentraient en réanimation
et je suis allée à l'hôpital récemment
je disais comment ça ça va il me disait
il ya trois lits de libre il ya 150
personnes qui attendent trois lits de
libre il ya des 150 personnes 14 ça
montre bien que nous sommes super
extrêmement critique de on va atteindre
les 600 morts et que nous avons bien sûr
cette obligation de nous mobiliser nous
sommes mobilisés avec les médecins
puisque le docteur bûcher que nous avons
à mener que nous pourrons écouter
échanger d'une politique globale
territoriales que j'expliquais tout à
l'heure avec le concept chambé nous la
tiens bon on est là nous avons signé
quatre 14,5 à quoi avec cinq maires de
communes la semaine cette semaine on en
fait 5 encore et chaque semaine on avait
cinq à dix communes de des sols qu'on
puisse soutenir sous le terrain ceux des
syndicats ont demandé la politique de
proximité socialement psychologiquement
et médicalement alors que tron partie de
notre émission la septième aujourd'hui
et demain serge letchimy président du
conseil exécutif la campagne électorale
est terminée depuis plusieurs mois
maintenant c'est vrai maintenant il faut
remettre il nous mettre une nouvelle
gouvernance en place tout d'abord
quelques questions sur les projets en
cours de quel état avez-vous trouvé à
ces thèmes à votre arrivée
vous savez on a clairement indiqué pas
de concombres pas d'histoires on a
raison d'une gouvernance apaisée ce
livre n'est pas de moi que je rende un
camp je n'y a pas rien de vous c'est
juste pour savoir oui quel lequel elle
est ou d une situation est extrêmement
difficile très difficile pour une raison
très simple il n'ya pas d'organigramme
qu'il faut construire un organigramme il
ya quand même quatre mille trois cents
salariés
nous nous avons une situation aussi
difficile ce plan budgétaire puisque le
niveau d'endettement actuellement et
de remboursement de la dette est de
25 ans le niveau accepté de manière de
l'anthologique par les experts et dachau
rural des comptes ces huit ans donc on a
explosé la possibilité d'emprunter j'ai
même réduisant points pour tenir le coup
ses 25 ans étaient graves et la dernière
chose c'est que nous avons pendant cette
dernière période
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup le
financement qui ne sont pas allés à
l'investissement mais qui sont plutôt
allés à des stabilité un peu politique
donc beaucoup de fonds qui ont été
étudiées comme cela et à ce titre là
nous sommes en train de reconstruire une
ligne budgétaire acceptable et d'avoir
une organisé sur et m ça c'est le
mauvais côté le bon côté c'est qu'on a
autour de quatre mille trois cents
salariés
parmi ses salariés beaucoup de personnes
très déterminée d'une très grande
compétence un personnel véritablement de
très grande qualité il suffit de les
organiser de tenir compte du cadre
social du dialogue social donc les
syndicats nous les écoutons beaucoup
nous sommes en train de faire de la ctn
un outil au service de la population et
c'est ça l'objectif pendant les trois
premiers on savait que deux mois et demi
nous avons pratiquement pris tout le
temps de l'émission on doit quand même à
vous poser une question il y a quinze
jours vous étiez à paris vous y avez
rencontré les principaux responsables
politiques de l'état ministre de
l'outre-mer ce que vous souhaitez et
notamment sur tout premier ministre ce
que vous souhaitez c'est surtout un
partenariat de développement de la
martinique c'est m&a pouvez vous nous
expliquer rapidement de manière très
synthétique on a comme un modèle de
fonctionnement au niveau de la
collectivité territoriale le modèle de
développement économique qui est qui à
mon avis n'est pas satisfaisant parce
que ça crée une telle précarité un
chômage ont provoqué qu'il faut changer
le monde et l'économie c'est pour ça que
j'ai proposé à l'état un cadre
partenarial de telle sorte qu'on puisse
définir d'abord nous mêmes avec les
acteurs économiques les tous les
responsables économiques une
organisation de développement qui permet
d'alimenter de trouver les voies d'une
une émancipation économique dans le sens
de la production interne et quand je dis
ça je pense à l'agriculture pense qu'il
faut vraiment aller vers l'autonomie
alimentaire si on veut pas que cet
exemple il ya plusieurs secteurs comme
la biodiversité de numérique le
développement de la grande
transformation du tourisme l'activité
d'attractivité du pays fougue le pays
soit attractif et pour cela il faut
négocier avec l'état n'ont pas seulement
des moyens militaires supplémentaires
mais aussi des moyens fiscaux des
possibilités de réglementer localement
des possibilités aussi de rentrer dans
un consensus qui puisse nous permettre
que de vouloir développer de plus
rapidement et intéresser les jeunes les
personnes âgées dans une nouvelle
dynamique de développement donc le cadre
étant fixée ça peut être un contrat de
partenariat pendant cinq six ans ou dix
ans qui pourrait nous permettre que le
signé avec l'état un nouveau cadre pour
propulser le payer nous arrivons
quasiment à la fin de l'émission sur
yoshi nous allons vous demander de
commenter une photo tirée de l'actualité
récente au sujet de la disparition de
lucette michaux chevry
avec après cinquante ans de vie
politique extrêmement active vous avez
eu l'occasion de lui rendre hommage sur
nos antennes que faut-il retenir de son
action beaucoup disent ici voyons que la
déclaration de bastien de 1999 à
laquelle elle a beaucoup contribué a été
un d'avancé dans un communiqué de la
demande d'autonomie de responsabilité
locale pour les élus locaux pour moi ce
que je retiens d'abord de lucette
michaux chevry c'est d'abord une femme
debout quoi c'est une femme forte et
c'est très important par rapport au
contexte de l'époque ce qu'on aura de ça
maintenant
il ya beaucoup de femmes en politique de
plus en plus et il faut qu'il y ait de
plus en plus
mais se soit vu cette messagerie a
vraiment briser le plafond de verre pour
permettre le rayonnement des femmes en
politique une première job est fait avec
brio la deuxième chose c'était une croix
de l'opn au sens pur du terme même si
elle était dans une dynamique nationale
connus avec son parti politique mais
c'était pas la guadeloupe avant tout
c'était un véritable rechercher les rois
les plus précises pour que son pays
puisse se développer elle a réalisé
beaucoup d'équipement des
infrastructures de très grande portée la
troisième chose c'est une femme
politique elle était très dans la
république mais en même temps elle
pensait la guadeloupe la possibilité
d'initiative locale calais compte de la
culture tenez compte copie du système
est connue je prends souvent l'exemple
d'un amendement que les proposer sur
l'économie informelle et je me suis
inspiré des travaux de lucette michaux
chevry qui voulaient codifié ce qu'on
appelle la polyactivité trouve remettre
à quelqu'un de voix être à la fois
chauffeur de taxi en même temps
travailler de l'autorisent et avant une
autre activité ça la polyactivité et
avoir les mêmes droits à la retraite 3
la formation professionnelle connaît pas
en tout cas c'est plutôt sociale non
mais lucette michaux chevry même si on
partage pas et la même ligne politique
c'est une femme chaque fois que j'en
vois de l'autre je lui rendais visite
merci beaucoup monsieur le président du
conseil exécutif d'avoir accepté notre
invitation pour cette seconde émission
alors merci à vous de votre fidélité
nous tenons à vous dire que notre
volonté pour cette émission c'est aussi
de vous donner la parole alors n'hésitez
pas à poser toutes vos questions d'ordre
économique politique ou social sur notre
numéro 06 96 22 40 90 enregistrez votre
question postés là nous et nous la
diffusons à nos prochains invités nous
vous donnons rendez vous lundi prochain
pour un nouveau numéro de politique pays
excellente soirée sur nous
[Musique]